So one of the problems was that Dev and
Ops were not talking with each other
early in the development process.
Ending up with incompatible environments
is a pretty bad result from that.
Suppose that Dev knew what Ops knows.
That the production system has to all
work together as an integrated unit that
can be tested and scaled.
It can't be patched together from pieces
the last minute before launch, and
suppose that Ops knew what Dev knows.
That the system under development
needs to change rapidly.
The technologies involved just
aren't going to be the same forever.
With that kind of shared knowledge,
Dev and
Ops could work together to come up
with a common deployment environment
that would work well both in
development and in production.
That would deploy well onto servers at
scale, while also developers make all of
the changes that they need
to build new features.
This is just one example of how
technical change can be made in
response to the social and
organizational challenges of DevOps.
There are different ways to implement
this particular change, but
first, let's take a look at the
situation in which this problem arises.